yes
oh
yeah we'll just move around
well the chair has to see it
something tells me everything somebody
came in here and measured exactly
yeah just straight back
not that i should point that out
it's not like
okay
it is nine o'clock we have a schedule
and the first
on our agenda is a
is the exotic aquatic weeds an animal
species committee presentation
uh representative smith would like to
introduce good morning committee members
and um
i am i serve as the chair of the aquatic
exotic weeds and species committee
and
representative creighton is also on this
committee we meet monthly and we
work with the agencies and other groups
to help mitigate
prevent
the outgrowth of aquatic invasives
whether weeds or
mussels or other things and so this is a
presentation that the committee has put
together and i'm joined today by
michelle tremblay who represents the new
hampshire rivers council
amy smagula from des and michelle davis
from new hampshire lakes who all are on
the
committee and i'm going to turn the
microphone over to michelle tremblay who
will take the lead and at the close of
the presentation
there will be time for questions and
that can be answered by any of us any of
us on the committee thanks
good morning everyone sort of like march
of the valkyries isn't it it's like this
whole parade of women that are talking
to you about invasive species
i'm really happy to be here and thanks
for your time on this i'm going to be
joined by experts uh amy smagula and
michelle davis if she wants to come up
and sit with us as well
and amy's going to provide color
commentary
just like it's a hockey hockey game
this is a serious threat to new
hampshire's waters and some are not
invaded yet and some are just ripe for
it depending on the access
and michelle's going to talk a little
bit about what's happening with trying
to prevent that
we're going to talk about the scope of
this the threat
our actions and others to mitigate the
risks and are we doing enough in spoiler
alert the answer is no okay one second
is there members of the committee who
can't see the screen if you'd like to
go out uh move out to the
to the area out
there uh
just
just looked like i don't know how you
can see you get around corners
anyone else
isn't there also that's uh
representative
spang's chair but yeah
and he's not there so
all right uh
please please continue yes i am sorry
for the interest no no thank you um mr
chair i think it's really important that
everybody's able to see it
all right it's a good view now of all
the horrible pictures we're going to
show you this morning
all right so the definition of invasive
species it's non-native earth alien to
our state
and the introduction is likely to cause
harm not only to the environment but in
some cases to human health
and here's a map i know that it's
difficult to see you will be receiving a
pdf of this presentation so you'll be
able to see things easier
but there's a list on the left of the
invasions themselves as well as where
they're located and often they are
co-located so a water body may be
threatened by multiple invasive species
and amy what's the current number um i
think we
had a current number for all of the
water bodies but this is a breakdown of
rivers and lakes
thank you amy
so you can see that invasive species
aren't just for lakes anymore rivers are
also threatened by invasive species
and the most threatening to ais to new
hampshire is variable milfoil and you
can see what a cove
in squam lake what can happen with a
complete takeover you can see that
there's a little bit of a channel that's
been cut by boats
just to get out into the open water
there's also fan wart this is a picture
from robinson pond as you can see
and then water chestnut i mentioned that
invasive species are now in rivers water
chestnut is
coming going across this river from bank
to bank
and then european or brittle niad this
is in six water bodies right now
and then moving on to animals this is
asian clam and this is in the merrimack
river in beau
and it's in a lot of lakes including um
is it
cobble pond in i'm not getting that
right
so it's not only just about aesthetics
and boating and swimming it's also
economic sectors
recreation and tourism boating can be
affected
and several years ago there was a report
called what's our water worth
and the perception of water quality when
there are plants that take over water
bodies as you see here they can reduce
property values so the redistribution of
property taxes or assessments
can change
and 25 percent of the water bodies you
can see in meredith make up over 50
percent of the town's total assessed
property value so when those values go
down as i said the tax or the assessment
is redis redistributed
across other properties and it affects
tourism which is 5 billion a year for
the state of new hampshire
that's recreational fishing visitors to
state parks and then out of state or
transient boaters all of them
have a perception or a real
perception of what our water is worth
and the water quality
if we talk about
more than just aesthetics and more than
just the pleasure of enjoying our lakes
and rivers there are other sectors that
are impacted none of these are in new
hampshire thank heaven for now
but you can see where it's a dam intake
there's marine structures agricultural
irrigation
power plants treatment plants and even
in the upper right you can see they've
clogged a water pipe this can happen
with a lot of invasive species but
particularly animals
from a cost standpoint prevention is
always the least expensive way to deal
with invasive species unfortunately it
doesn't get the heart stirred up when
everything looks wonderful you don't
think that you need to put in an effort
and you don't think that you need to
spend the money but this is actually
where the least amount of money is spent
once
when you move on to early detection that
means that you have people such as
michelle davis's program we'll talk
about that in a moment and river runners
which the new hampshire rivers council
runs that's the idea of making sure that
there's surveillance so that you can
catch invasive species before they take
over
from there it moves into rapid response
so you want to make sure that you are
jumping on the problem
making sure that you're not letting it
go and turning into a bank to bank or an
entire cove infestation
and sadly you can see that once you get
to treatment and control and long-term
management the dollars go up really what
you're doing is holding back the tide
which is challenging to say the least
and very expensive to say the most
prevention and early detection we
mentioned the lake hosts
weed watchers river runners and various
other outreach to check boats to talk to
people about how these things can be
spread
and then there's the best available
technologies to prevent ais and michelle
do you want to tell us about this
trailer that we're looking at
uh so the the photo in the center is a
it's called a cd3 unit it's clean drain
dry and dispose
this is a pilot program that new
hampshire lakes has been running for
about three years now
and this is a mobile
solar powered waterless
watercraft like boat cleaning station
this is sort of the the cadillac of cd3
units there are
other smaller options and there are
options that are stationary so the goal
of the program is to
increase awareness of the threat of
aquatic invasive species of course and
and increase boater awareness of the
importance of cleaning draining and
drying their boats
when they're entering or leaving
water bodies and so this particular unit
has
a wet vacuum on it
it has a
pressurized air to dry the your boat
and it also has some tools to clean and
um and grab
plant fragments off of the boat um and
there's a there's a
uh
what is the wrench called with the
that opens the
yeah the drain wrench thank you um
that so you can you can um empty your
your live well so um new hampshire lakes
has been deploying this this unit around
the state um for two this year and last
year for two week increments at
different boat ramps um with the hope
that
uh local local groups and um communities
will eventually purchase
units of their own that will be
stationary this is
a great tool it's not
it's not necessarily the best option for
every ramp if you think of small
sloped dirt ramps this may not be the
best option but it is a it is a great
tool um for the for the places that are
appropriate for it but other other
options for best available technologies
to prevent aquatic invasive species are
you know garden hoses um even just
simple tools to to reach under your boat
and grab plant fragments like i
mentioned
and there's also options um like if any
of you have visited lake george in new
york state
they have hot water
high pressure boat cleaning stations
which
are a lot more expensive and again not
necessarily
appropriate for all boat launches here
in new hampshire
thank you michelle and
this unit is really interesting and i
wondered if you wanted to talk a little
bit about
where people can clean their own boats
so that they're not essentially washing
invasive species
into the water body and do you want to
talk about lake post now sure i can do
that
um
yeah so it's really important as you're
leaving the lake to
not be washing your boat in a space
where
the the water is going to run back into
the lake and then potentially
result in a new infestation
um
and um so you can
often times they'll be um
at sort of are the best possible ramps
there'll be
locations that you can pull off to the
side where you can clean your boat and
there'll be disposal
stations for any sort of plant fragments
that you do pull off your boat um and
then as far as the lake host program
goes new hampshire lakes has been
running the lake coast program are
facilitating the lake host program for
about 20 years now
and the lake host program
partners with local groups to
staff boat ramps
so that people can help
boaters check their boats for aquatic
invasive species and the courtesy boat
inspection program this year we are
anticipating about 80 groups
participating
and that is a total of about 700 paid
and volunteer at lake hosts
last in 2021 we had 15 saves and those
are specimens prevented from entering a
water body
and several of those saves were at on in
currently uninfested water bodies
and then the weed watcher program and
the river runner program that michelle
mentioned
is a volunteer program where
people will
periodically throughout the summer
paddle
or around their lakes and and look in
the shallow waters and try to
try to catch an infestation sort of
early on for that that early detection
and so
people volunteer to do that on both
rivers and lakes
and i think it's you know once a month
that they that they paddle around so
it's a group effort but i would note
also that
volunteerism generally in new hampshire
is going down and so every year we are
noticing it being harder and harder for
local groups to hire both paid and
volunteer
lake coast and and the weed watcher
river runner program is also struggling
thank you michelle that's a really
important point to bring up when we
talked about the costs is that new
hampshire runs on volunteers that
includes all of you i know you have high
salaries but
we all consider you to be volunteers as
well and for river runners one of the
things that's interesting is that they
don't often make saves as you describe
to us negative findings or data but for
volunteers they can often lose interest
so that continuum that we showed you
where it's less costly when there's
nothing going on and you're conducting
surveillance
that makes it difficult to keep people
engaged because we all like to rally
around a crisis but when it comes to
prevention it gets a little bit trickier
so now we are at that point of rapid
response treatment and control and
earlier amy and i were discussing divers
it used to be that there were more
people that did this as volunteers but
now it's contractors so you can see hand
pulling
the diver assistant suction harvest so
you can all sound like insiders now and
just say dash because it sounds cool
benthic barriers which i believe aren't
used as much as they used to be and then
herbicide application which is often
controversial with late groups and
communities
and then the most expensive is long-term
management these five-year long plans
have developed been developed for 65
water bodies is that current amy
and they integrate a number of
management techniques which are
pulling
herbicides and they utilize public park
public private partnerships
the state agencies that are responsible
one full-time employee
it is her
super amy
seasonal interns is available and it is
funded from boat registration fees the
general fund and then the decals
the department of agriculture markets
and food is the
division of pesticide control they
provide the permits for herbicide
application
and they have a one partial full-time
equivalent so that means part of a
person we hope that we get the head and
at least an arm to sign permits on that
part of a person
new hampshire fish and game they are
responsible for invasive animals whereas
des is responsible for plants
they have no staff or funding dedicated
to this right now we have been working
on it and they don't have any monitoring
or rapid response plans in place
our committee was established by you in
the members include legislators state
agencies non-profit public members and
we're essentially a long-term study
committee i know that that raises
questions with a lot of people as far as
having long-term committees but it
really has provided a long-term and
focused basis
on what we can do with invasive species
so not only deciding to introduce a bill
but being able to sort of be in place
to study an issue and make
recommendations
the funding as you can see again we'll
send this to you as a pdf but the
funding for ais activities has gone up
with the boat registrations
and amy has this leveled off i heard
that this had leveled off as far as how
many boats are going to be registered
and be part of the revenue stream
but we were steady at 96 000.
right so we'll we'll maybe update this
before we send out the pdf then
great thank you
amy so you can see the funding uh the
general funds the decals the private
donations and municipal funds
and then we won't
torture your eyes with this but the
expenditures have obviously gone up with
the demand
the control grants amy can you tell us a
little bit more about the grant program
are you sure yeah okay
all right so you can see that the grant
program has gone up these grants are not
only for research but they're also for
programs such as the new hampshire lakes
for lake host
and others that need to apply herbicides
to control invasive species
but here's the interesting thing
municipal funding makes up the most of
what is dedicated to invasive species
this is match
these are funds that communities raise
because they feel like their water
bodies are important to them locally
private funding this would be
foundations this would be individual
donations and then you can see the state
is actually a small part of that
this works well right now but there is a
need for more
and having the state be the smallest
part of this when these are part of the
public trust these are public waters
seems like we would want to dedicate
more of our state funds to it
so the threat is serious and it will
increase
they continue to grow just one
fragment of a weed can take root so to
speak in the water or in the
sediment
and when you have for instance shallow
waters where a lot of sun reaches it the
sediments are there they're full of
nutrients this is a ripe area to grow
anything and then fragments can float
around and that they can grow
so
the lake host program is one of the most
impressive in the region it's being
treated as a model right now for many
other states that want to do it but as
michelle pointed out even with the paid
people they can't reach everywhere all
the time
so we do need your support you are the
committee that makes the decision about
these and your leadership is very
important to talk about funding the
partnerships how we can increase our
work the outreach that's very important
to educate people
and as an example of what we can do
together that horror picture that we
showed right in the beginning
that on the right is before pardon me
after milfoil management so it's not
going to go away completely this is the
kind of place where invasive species not
just milfoil will grow
so it's a success story but we have to
remain vigilant on it
this is the membership of the study
committee so you can see that lakes
rivers
particular water bodies some of your
alumni such as john mullen
representative creighton is here
senators heads of state agencies and
then staff such as amy smagula are
represented
that's all that we have today to show
you for the good and the bad pictures
and we welcome your questions
i have uh one first uh
first one in
and then i'll recognize representative
post and the represent
well i'm losing air so
but anyway let me get my question in uh
do you have any federal funding at all
the federal funding is coming
and it is variable if i can explain that
for a moment state management plans have
to be approved by the u.s fish and
wildlife services aquatic nuisance
species task force
this is part of my day job so to speak
the rivers council is volunteer but
these state management plans are drafted
with agency cooperation they receive
funding each year there's a big pot of
money and depending on which state
management plans are approved and if
they apply for funding they get a piece
of the pizza so to speak so everyone
gets a slice of it that slice varies
every year depending on those factors so
the money is coming the plan has been
reviewed and amy are you anticipating
november or the spring
yep so the spring of 2023 is when the
task force will likely approve the plan
and then applications can be made at
that time
but amy i'm not aware of any other
federal funding coming
it's an excellent question
representative post and representative
gould
thank you mr chair and thank you for
presenting this today it was very
interesting um as far as the lake hosts
some people um doing the um
looking for the weeds and things like
that and you said you don't get many
volunteers has there been an outreach to
communities and
if so
do you have classes or anything to
that people can go to to participate in
this and and
has there been a reach out in
communities with a lot of lakes or even
ponds or rivers that
people can check on their own or get a
group together to do it so the way the
program works is that
new hampshire lakes facilitates the
program in the sense that
we
manage lake host payroll
and we
train lake hosts
we've switched to this training as you
can imagine with the pandemic to a lot
of online training
but lake hosts are trained to identify
potential threatened or potential
threatening species and remove them from
the boats
we partner with lake associations so the
lake association would approach us
they apply for the program annually so
so programs have been running for 20
years um and so we're sort of the the
top of the umbrella and the and the lake
and each individual lake association
is responsible for hiring
and organizing and scheduling their lake
hosts
and so that's where you get that mix of
volunteer and and paid so some and and
it requires a matching grant so we will
that that control grant that that was
mentioned earlier new hampshire lakes
gets that and then distributes it out
among lake associations and then they
are also required to provide matching
funds um
for the for their program um so
and then we are also you know spreading
the word about the lake post program
i believe my colleague is is presenting
at
um
and i'm trying to remember the name of
the organization
but it's an organization um focus on
volunteerism and so she's she's
presenting at that meeting i believe
tonight
about the lake coast program just to
just to continue to spread the word and
share the opportunity to to lake host
for other people is that the state's
volunteer new hampshire organization
it may be
yeah
for a follow-up um so so my second
question is for folks that don't live in
a lake community but would like to
participate in this how would they go
about doing that i think that they would
just they would contact their local lake
association and i'm sure they could
contact new hampshire lakes who could
put them in touch with
the the lake host coordinator in a
nearby community but i think that you
know if they if they've got a lake that
they have a personal attachment to
contacting the lake coast or the lake
association on that lake would be
the best bet but reaching out to new
hampshire lakes is also an option
one more follow-up
do you um look at ponds and things like
that i i know we have in our just in our
neighborhood because we're in a hilly
community it starts up here goes into a
river another pond is all the way down
is there any control or or
a way to look at those or are you
looking at those
places as well
because they're what eventually will go
into our rivers
are we looking at them for lake host
programs
right
to check on on those waterways and
things like that a lot of people go
kayaking in those ponds um
they they they could be what we consider
swamps but they're large bodies of water
um
yeah i mean i think so
for the lake host program specifically
the initiating the the development of a
lake host program on a body of water
is the the responsibility of initiating
that that falls on the local community
so that local lake association
and so if there is interest
the the local community would have to
initiate that program so come to new
hampshire lakes and and receive that
information in that training
oh and i was just gonna say really
quickly um lake host focuses on boat
ramps so boats coming in and out of
those access points for weed watchers
state of new hampshire
groups can ask to be trained with it and
with river runners we do something
similar where we look for hosts
such as a chamber of commerce it can be
a local
lake association or river association
i've given trainings at all of them
and that is focused on people that are
already on the water so we teach them to
do what we call transects so they can go
along the shore either in a boat or they
can walk along the shore they're bird
watching they're fishing so we're
looking for people that are already on a
river or a lake in some cases lakes have
asked us to come
so we're not looking at the access
points with the equipment to do the
saves we're looking to see if people who
are already there are noticing something
different and training their eyes toward
that
great thank you
okay thank you for taking my question
actually you brought up something to me
because a kayaker for example or a
canoer can go into the water just
between a couple bushes so being on the
water to catch them is good but the
question i had i was curious how much is
that cadillac trailer how much does it
cost
uh the cd3 unit that we purchased was
around forty thousand dollars forty five
thousand forty thousand okay but there
are so and and
part of what made that trailer
specifically more expensive is because
it is a mobile unit
there are units that are designed to be
installed permanently um and there are
there are units that are designed
without the solar panels on top that if
there's um elec electricity available
can be used and so there are smaller
units that don't have the vacuum or the
forced air they just have
some tools attached to it
there's a whole there's a whole i think
there's four different units that that
can be purchased at varying price points
okay thank you
can you get a cadillac for forty
thousand dollars
yeah it and your objective is to show
people what can be done and hopefully
they'll buy their own and have it be
stationary or they can share a mobile
right yes
thank you
yeah i think on my river
which everyone assumes is flows straight
from god's own
source
no one would really think to look for
invasive species
if something were
how would like the
rivers associations find out about it so
that they could leap into action
i think that probably unless they were
part of a program like river runners or
it was found at lake host then they
would probably contact environmental
services directly
that is my guess and with river runners
we have neat little zip blocks that
amy's program provides we ask people to
put them with a wet paper towel in there
and then we identify them if we get
stuck we ask amy to identify them so
it's a tricky question representative
spang because
i think it would rely on the finder so
to speak knowing where to send it so if
your association is interested in a
training i'd be happy to talk with you
about that and get people's eyes trained
toward it and also know what to do if
they find something
suspicious
so it is up to the
watershed association to take the
initiative
to find out if there's a problem
um rather than to wait and find out to
hear from someone else like the river
runners that a problem has been found
yeah i think if they're if they're
trained to understand and see something
different because they're out there all
the time i think you your lakers your
pardon me your river watershed
association is ideally poised
to be able to do that and you might um
have people after training or even now
that are able to look at something right
away and say oh that's fine or
that's a problem heaven forbid or
we need help to identify it further some
of the samples can be quite degraded
particularly at the end of the season
and so those get pretty tricky and often
amy i think we found a sample once that
you sent off for dna testing because it
was so tricky
and that's kind of the last resort
because it costs money but it's
important great thank you thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question what is your
recommendation for lake and river
residents who find something if they see
milfoil there or they see phragmites
there do you recommend that they pull
them up do you recommend that they try
to treat them on their own or order
chemicals online what are your
suggestions there um i absolutely don't
don't pull it don't try to treat it
yourself um the the nature of these
weeds um are that
they are you know invasive and and
prolific and so um the brittle nyad was
an example um it's
it's prone to breaking
and when the weeds
break that they'll float into other
places and establish in other places um
the same with with milfoil and that's
why it's particularly concerning when
boat propellers go through areas that
are infested because they're chopping up
these
these plants and then
there's plants that are a floating and
then b potentially caught in the
propellers and being being transported
to other areas of the lake that aren't
currently infested or other other water
bodies entirely
and you mentioned phragmites it's the
bane of my existence i've been working
on a river restoration and the
phragmites spread so quickly and so
prolifically it's important also to know
purple loose strife is another example
when you're working with someone who
knows what they're doing timing is
everything because you don't want to be
pulling or cutting or moving anything
when you could be spreading seeds
and also rhizomes so where you dispose
of them is key as well but it's a really
really good question so don't touch it
until you contact someone who
understands what to do and when to do it
please
yeah i was uh trained as part of my lake
association many years ago by amy who
came out and did a training for weed
watchers and if i am out kayaking
anywhere in the state i'm always keeping
my eyes open and at one point i even
took a picture of a weed and emailed it
to amy and said i found this and where i
found it and then she was able to tell
me you're okay or no send me the sample
in a plastic bag
so it's
anytime you're out kayaking if you know
any of your weeds you can do a little
bit of your own
sleuthing amy responds to texts really
quickly so i'm sure she gets a lot of
those pictures and that's a very fast
way to get an answer eight o'clock at
night
four o'clock in the morning
i get responses really fast
representative huff for a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question this is a big
question
this is a very difficult problem i can
relate to it
on my family's property
we used to have crystal clear water when
i was a kid i could drink it i could
open my eyes under the water and see as
clearly as i'm seeing you right now
now there's milfoil in it
so my question is
in a perfect situation
and we are all agreeable
what do you want from us that we can
give you to help either make this stop
or mitigate it the best and i say this
like a wish list don't hold back what
money what legislation would you like to
see to make it work
i hate things to always come down to
money because it's part of the answer
it's not the entire answer but funding
is really important um
amy can tell us about the backlog of
what she cannot fund and then it's also
things where people
just give up
so they're not even applying for fun so
i think that's a big part of it
i think michelle you touched on another
thing which is we're sort of
climbing
a bell curve
of where what tends to be older retired
people are doing this work because they
have time they live on a lake
uh unfortunately that's something we're
seeing a decline and we're not able to
find as many new younger volunteers as
we once wore
legislation i think is key
it's a difficult question as you said or
a big question because
this is the live free or die state i was
born here i'm part of it and it's
difficult to regulate and tell people
what they can't do it's easier for us to
talk about what people can do
so we might need to craft our messages
and legislation
to talk about cans and incentives for
those better behaviors
so that's my thought and michelle and
amy and madam chair
would welcome your input on that because
it is a big question and we want to make
sure
that you hear everything that we're able
to do
thank you for that question so
like the lady said this is a
multi-pronged approach so we need the
prevention we need the early detection
we need the long-term management so all
of those things need to be supported
further
we need more clean drain dry systems for
prevention around the state for people
to do disinfection and decontamination
of their watercraft so these things stop
spreading we need more volunteers out
there to weed watch and report things
early to me so we can do management and
then we also need the funding for that
management we did an exercise where we
evaluated what it would cost each year
to control the 91 infested water bodies
across the state
and that's
that's a 10 million ticket each year for
a few years and then it you know of
course we'll taper down as we get ahead
of the big infestations that are out
there
right now we don't have those resources
we're only managing half of the water
bodies that are infested and that's a
matching grant program
so in 2022 we're projected to spend six
million dollars on milfoil and fan war
and water chestnut control on just half
of the water bodies across the state
so
that doesn't even include the more
complicated systems like river systems
so
resources for prevention and control are
critical
we are currently in the exotic aquatic
weeds and species committee putting
together
a
the plan that michelle mentioned that
will help bring in a little bit of
federal dollars but it will also
identify a strategy going forward to
enhance the program so we'll probably at
some point be coming back with
additional items not this year or next
year but probably you know coming in the
next few years to tackle that
and which water body are you referencing
which lake are ponds
okay yeah yep
year every couple years
um they come through and they treat and
you know they give us the warning don't
go swimming or let your pets near the
water for a day or two
and it seems to
have
uh
it hasn't cleared it out
but it it stops it from continuing i
mean is this still i have to go through
the 20-foot
you know swim of grossness to get out to
the to the center before it's it's it's
clear um so you know i can totally
relate to this stuff and that's why i
was i was curious yeah so for all the
water bodies to kind of wrap into all
the questions that came up
we do this layered approach of
prevention early detection management so
that we can try to get ahead of the
infestations so ultimately if you are on
a water body or work with a water body
that doesn't have any of those layers
present we should work to get those
built up pagas does have a lot of those
built in
and we've been working our way through
winnipesaukee as a whole and as you know
winnipesaukee
is large and we've had to address all of
the infestations in all of the towns
before we address pagas otherwise
there's no point in addressing it
because everything flows through pagas
so you are
in the holding pattern but we are slowly
working our way through pagas too but
yeah if you are related to working with
living on a water body that has an issue
feel free to reach out and we'll get you
in the queue for management or i can
provide you with an update of where we
are with with management
yes
and one last thing
on that question is something called
command model
and my father was in the army and navy
so you never know who you're gonna cheer
for in a football game but
he uh he can still
okay
[Laughter]
the command model is something that a
lot of states have explored because this
is something that you use in an
emergency this is something that you use
when it comes to something like a flood
for instance
and invasive species can be an emergency
and so i went through an exercise where
we brought in different agencies to talk
about the command model and it's
something to consider in the future
maine had a hydrilla infestation
in a basically a fly-in kind of pond
and all of the agencies tried to come
together and there were many obstacles
to it so having a command model in place
to begin with could be part of a rapid
response plan
um and we talked about that that's sort
of the third step in that continuum so
we can talk about that in the future i'm
going to turn things over to madam chair
unless there's any other questions but
that's that's a whole other discussion
and it's kind of an exciting discussion
two to have because that could be the
way that we are able to jump into action
sooner rather than let something get out
of hand
we do have a hearing
at nine
at 9 45
i don't
is i know we've seen one person has
signed up is there
is the prime sponsor here
uh yeah
i don't see the the prime sponsor i
don't see the prime sponsor for the
uh
452 so i'll
let this go a little longer until i see
the prime sponsor come in
uh you have a question uh representative
post oh we got lots of questions
martin
no i just thought we were going to close
so uh well i i i will close uh
well
actually you haven't had a question yet
uh for you know actually i don't have a
question i think i have information if
the prime sponsor is senator
d'alessandro he is currently
why i was late
on the senate committee on ways and
means hearing
house bill 1598 which is the
commercialization cannabis bill which is
very popular today and so there's a lot
of folks over here
oh here we go look at that okay
okay
all right
let's say
um
so i will i will close the presentation
and in part answering uh representative
huff's question but also to everyone is
just about every bill related to aquatic
invasive species comes through this
committee and usually we give the
presentation early in the session when
there is pending legislation there was
no legislation this year but if you hear
us talk about the enabling legislation
for the best available technology that
came through this the decal for
out-of-state voter
voters any increase in registration fees
usually passes pretty easily because
everyone wants it to happen because they
all know the value of
fighting aquatic invasives but anyway so
that's why it's so important to for us
to be giving this presentation to this
committee so if legislation comes up
next january you'll go aha i know what
about this is about so
but thank you for your time and it's
been a pleasure to be here on this side
of the table thank you very good
i will
close the presentation
uh do you need to clean up anything
before we start the the hearing and
on
what is this
452.
when i'm doing three things at once we
end up with a rather large and long
list of stuff
okay
all right is
i have one card so far for uh
452 we have another one okay and uh
all right
okay
uh
i will open the hearing on
house
house bill yep
senate bill
uh 452 relative to lead in drinking
water in schools and licensed child care
center
centers and
the chair recognized senator
d'allesandro
and
can't help but recognize senator
d'alessandro he looks the same as when
we
i've seen him
you know 20 years and going on
and he never changes
i don't know what you eat senator but
thank you thank you mr chairman it's the
good food that my wife prepares yes that
keeps me alive and well it must be the
the italian food it's got to be got to
be
same thing here
thank you thank you mr chairman and
distinguished members of the committee
for the record i'm senator lou
d'alessandro i represent district 20
manchester awards 3 4 10 11 in the town
of goffstown
and i come before you as the prime
sponsor
of a senate bill 452
relative to leaded drinking water
the purpose of senate bill 452 fn is to
protect protect drinking water in
schools and child care facilities
the issue is that children are being
exposed to lead through contaminated
drinking water in schools and child care
facilities
no amount of lead is safe for a child to
ingest
even small amounts of lead can result in
irreversible irreversible harm including
loss of cognitive ability and behavioral
problems
the best way to protect children is to
prevent lead exposure in the first place
in the last biennium the water trust
gave the department of education 1.8
million dollars to remove lead pipes
from schools and to deal with lead in
schools drinking water i might say to
the best of my knowledge about 70 000 of
that 1.8 million has been spent now
obviously schools were closed because of
the covet problem
but but indeed the 1.8 million dollars
specifically to deal uh with this
problem
the epa reported that lead in drinking
water contributes to 20 percent
of a person's total exposure to lead
as a result sb 247 enacted in 2018
requires that schools and child care
facilities must test their drinking
water for lead results from the
subsequent tests revealed widespread
lead contamination in schools throughout
new hampshire i think about 20 000 tests
are still a matter of record this bill
will retain those tests so people will
be able to to use them as a as a point
with ninety percent of schools
conducting tests forty percent of those
schools reported lead in drinking water
twenty-five percent of the results
reported led between one and five parts
per billion
ten percent of the results uh revealed
led between five and fifteen parts per
billion
five percent of the of the results
reported and led over 15 parts
per billion currently schools and child
care facilities are only required to
remediate lead in drinking water when it
exceeds a federal standard of 15 parts
per billion
the federal standard of 15 parts per
billion is not a health based standard
it comes from ees lead in cup and copper
rule
the epa's maximum standard for lead and
drinking water is zero
the american academy of pediatrics
health-based recommendations is for no
more than one part per billion of lead
in in drinking water
sp 452 solution to this problem is
removing lead and drinking water by
establishing a health-based limit of one
part per billion now the bill says up to
five parts per billion but so that's a
change that has has taken place the bill
requires schools
and licensed child care facilities to
test drinking water for lead and to
notify parents of tests with with high
standards
uh the bill has been amended in the
senate you have you have the amendment
the results of the tests are retained
and up to five parts per uh per billion
has been taken into consideration
i can't express my concern for how
important this is
i as a youngster dealt with lead pipe
my father was a plumber i was an
apprentice to my father and we would go
into homes and buildings that had lead
pipes because that was the way you
you piped water in the old days
there are many uh
many places where that still exists the
lead pipe has been constantly removed
and
it's the proper thing to do
but indeed in schools as i said the 1.8
million dollars came from the trust it
was supposed to be used uh
to take care of light problems in in
schools
and uh as i said because of
obviously the culvert problem only about
70 million has been used 70 000 has been
used so there's money available to do
this and it's very very important
all of all of you who have children
recognize the fact that they spend time
obviously in school a great portion of
their
primary care is taken is taken care of
in a school and they use the bubbler and
they use drinking water in the schools
we've dealt with problems with drinking
water for a long period of time
at one time in my life i was president
of manchester water works and we take
pride in our water in manchester
it's as good as any any in the state and
we sell a lot of it to to different
communities in the state but we have a
process of treating that water which i
think is extensive
it's very important and it's among the
best
treatment of water
that exists in the country so we've
taken taken steps we need to take more
steps here so i thank you very much for
listening to my testimony i
i
i apologize for that fact that i have to
leave because i'm in ways of means and
we're having a committee hearing on
marijuana as we speak
and it's quite high
okay so uh
with with that idiomatic expression
uh i will i will leave you and uh
appreciate your support of this bill and
uh hopefully i could if i could address
any questions i'd be more than happy to
do that so thank you mr chairman thank
you members of the committee your
distinguished body spread out quite
beautifully here
you know sometimes i wonder when i get a
question from over here i wonder where
it's coming from i gotta grab it there
or grab it here and that but you're
doing a great job in addressing the
problems that we face and uh i
appreciate this opportunity for you take
some uh questions from members of the
committee
uh
representative
smith for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question um i do realize
there was a house bill uh
very similar to this
and we also had a bill earlier this year
uh related to pfas and drinking water
and one of the big issues sticking
points we came up against was
testing every outlet
was going to be
cross-prohibitive
and
i noticed that this bill has a testing
of every outlet which is every drinking
water fixture in the school
and
i know that the house bill as
amended by the senate talks about
installing water bottle filling stations
would you have an issue with putting
that option into this bill so it would
be less cost prohibitive to test every
outlet oh thank you very much for you
for your comment and your question i
know i i i don't have any problem we we
heard that bill yesterday in senate
finance about the uh
the water containers and and uh
no i don't have any i don't have any
problem with that as long as it's safe
and that's my concern
is the safety of of people as i'm sure
is as a concern of everybody uh before
me
so
our best
we have the tests that have been taken
and we have that as a in a depository
we've got that data to look at so i have
no problem with you with your question
and obviously we want to keep the costs
down but as i say
we've we've a pro
via the the trust we've got 1.8 million
there for the schools that they could
use and that
you know that's available and that's
obviously a cost
a cost saving situation because they get
it
they get to use it and the doe is
responsible for the repayment
thank you thank you bib
thank you very much seeing no other
questions by members of the committee
okay representative creighton and then
see if we can get the senator back to
his marijuana bill all right
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
um
the bill makes sense there's two things
i don't
completely understand the first is
you've got the january 2016. is this
adding on to a previous bill i mean
what i don't understand is is why are we
talking about
tests that have already completed what
required those tests
and and does this bill add on to some
previous legislation
uh thank you for the question i'm not
sure there have been a number of bills
actually there are a couple that are in
place as we speak and there has been
previous legislation and the tests that
have been taken
uh
that they were a matter of record we
want to retain those tests and retain
that database so we could look into that
but this bill is required then to
make more tests the other bills no
longer valid
no the the tests are valid
and the the other the other legislation
that's running too talks about 180 day
period that's rather confusing the one
bill that we that we uh looked at
yesterday i think this is a a clearer
situation
and i think uh is much much easier to
much easier to dissect and move forward
with okay thank you
follow on please
yeah
in here
and you mentioned one part per billion
um but in a bill it says five parts per
bill
you addressed it but i didn't catch
thank you
be we'd love it to be one part per
billion but we we the latitude is up to
five parts okay so the bill is set at
five yes with one as a stretch goal but
it's not right but no no nothing greater
than five thank you thank you
thank you
thank you very much seeing no other
questions thank you very much let you
get back to
you know
the business at hand yes
you know i once had a bill to introduce
gaming into the state i know
this this
this is an analogy they go on forever
they have a life of their own
as
people came in
[Music]
heidi tremarco from the conservation law
foundation
hello heidi tremarco with the
conservation law foundation
i want to thank the chair
and members of the committee for hearing
my testimony today
so clf strongly supports this bill sb
452 which does build on previous bills
that have required all the schools to
test for lead in their drinking water
and to remediate that lead
the prior bill was sb 247 which what
passed about i think was 2018 and that
required all the schools in licensed
child care facilities to test for the
presence of lead and the schools have
been doing that since that time and they
in fact had started testing before that
and that is why the bill dates back to
2016 so that
we capture all those tests the schools
have already invested in and i
understand the schools have already done
about 23 000 tests so it's quite a lot
so we want to um not throw out those
testing results so
the bill so the schools are already
testing for lead
but currently
they only need to remediate that lead if
it hits over 15 parts per billion or
higher and that's quite a high amount of
lead there is scientific consensus as
you heard from the senator that no
amount of lead in a child's bloodstream
is considered safe even a small amount
can lead to permanent brain damage for a
child
and so
with that scientific consensus that the
no amount of blood lead in their blood
is safe
we need to limit the amount of lead that
children are receiving through their
drinking water and the epa estimates
that a person can get up to 20 percent
of their
lead exposure through drinking water so
it's a significant source
the current level at f at 15 is not a
health based level it's tied to the
epa's lead and copper rule and epa
itself says that is not a health based
limit so it's not meant to be used to
set a health level for lead and drinking
water and the epa has an unenforceable
maximum contaminant level goal so epa's
suggested level is zero lead in drinking
water
the cdc also recommends zero and the
american
american academy of pediatrics
specifically recommends a limit of one
let one part per billion lead in school
drinking water so there's
consensus around this zero to one you
know depending where the test and limit
is as you heard the bill has been
amended up to five parts per billion
um we would still advocate for a lower
number but we but five is a huge
improvement over the current standard of
15 parts per billion
i would urge the committee to consider
a level of our neighboring states maine
and vermont both limit the amount of
lead in school drinking water to four
parts per billion
but four or five any of them are much
safer and more protective than the
current level of 15 parts per billion
there's significant cost savings that
there's a study by the pew center that
recommends that for every one dollar
invested in lead poisoning prevention we
could see as much as 17 return on the
investment because there's a lot of
societal costs and individual costs when
a child is poisoned by lead
and that those costs stay with them
through their lifetime so it affects the
child and there's a lot of societal
costs in special education and then um
you know as they're an adult even
through the criminal justice system so
investing in lead prevention upfront
makes a lot of sense both for the child
and for our society
and so on that and i'll just say that in
in previous before the senate the
american academy of pediatrics the new
hampshire medical society the new
hampshire school nurses association and
new hampshire legal assistance have all
supported this bill
and so we urge you to
vote that sb 452 ought to pass
representative spang for a question
i i i cannot say who it was that how it
got negotiated out up to the five
um
you know
this bill is the mechanism to reduce it
from the current standard of 15 down to
five or four or one so
i think it depends on where the
political appetite is for getting the
bill passed um
foreign
yeah i think you hit two of those
concerns so one of them is the
laboratory sensitivity and i i have
heard um but i des could speak to this
better but i understand that some labs
can test at one or at two you know
that's where their uh margin of error
where they're most comfortable some two
half a part per billion some to one and
some to two another concern is the
funding it was as you lower the number
you capture more faucets and systems
that need to be remediated and currently
there is a grant for funding
for the schools at five parts per
billion or higher so there's funding at
five
although i understand that that grant
could be
the
requirements of that grant could be
amended it could be made lower so it
could apply to remediation at levels of
between one and five
but that's where the current funding is
um through the chair please
okay
all right i'll
allow it
um
no that is through the um
the
the new hampshire it's the
okay
representative grassy then followed by
representative huff
yes thank you for taking my question um
what's here in five uh in 452 uh a lot
of it has been integrated into house
bill 1421 which is in senate finance i
guess just yesterday
and um
and it's got a lot of other stuff that's
in there is is 1421 hospital 1421
is that something you would support as
well
in general we do support the use of
water bottle filling stations which is
in 1421
i think the con
the concern about filling stations is
that
the other taps or sources of water in
the schools still need to be tested
so currently filling stations are used
as a remediation technique
and
we we would be fine with filling
stations as an alternative to testing as
long as the with a couple caveats the
other taps including like food
preparation areas or classroom sinks
where you know i know my children are
not always going to the water bottle
filling station if there's a classroom
sink they're going to use that
so you still need testing at the other
sources and remediation
and um you know the filling stations
have to be um up to certain you know
standards nsi standards to make sure
that they are reducing lead at the
appropriate amount
represent representative huff
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
uh taking my question um how many
i don't know if you know
the stat but how many uh school-age
children a year in new hampshire
diagnosed with lead
poisoning i should know that statistic
and i don't know it off the top of my
head do you know
no i know dhs dhhs tracks those numbers
and they are available on their website
and it's it's a significant amount it's
alarming how many children in new
hampshire are poisoned by that
follow-up for a follow-up
um and
i know you don't have the number but my
next question presuming that we can get
that number would be how many of those
can be linked to the school that they
attend and i don't believe that dhhs has
linked any of those exposure cases to a
specific school what we do know so the
children are kind of tested in two ways
their blood is tested at the
pediatrician's office at age one and two
although with the pandemic those numbers
the testing numbers have dropped off
significantly so a lot of children are
not being tested right now
and then the school drinking water is
tested and we have those results and we
know from those results that there is
lead in the school drinking water so
those are kind of two ways of knowing
how children are being exposed to lead
and
um
we would be in favor of tackling lead in
all the avenues that children are thank
you
seeing no
dish
seeing no more questions
thank you very much thank you
chair
calls
leanne atwell from the new hampshire
d-e-s
she has some copies of
information
i mean this is this is what uh you sent
out on uh
email
okay this was emailed yesterday
yes
this there was emails these copies were
emailed out also yesterday
thank you
okay
thank you very much representative
thank you thank you chairman and members
of the committee
my name is leanne atwell i work for new
hampshire department of environmental
services in the drinking water and
groundwater bureau and i manage the
program that tests school and child care
facility drinking water for lead
we've passed out
a letter of testimony from des that was
also emailed to the committee yesterday
and attached to the letter there is a
copy of the language of the current
language of h bill hb 1421 as well as a
table on the last page that summarizes
the key
differences and similarities between the
bills
des is not taking a position on this
bill but we would ask the committee to
consider
adopting provisions that are in hb 1421
to make the bills the bills consistent
so you'll see on on the summary the main
difference with hb 1421 is that there
was a provision added whereby schools
and child care facilities could have the
option of installing water bottle
filling stations in lieu of testing and
remediating every outlet
at their facility
and in the language that's included in
hb 1421 it has provisions about how many
station water bottle filling stations
should be installed and what type should
be installed
the
the station should be tested after
they've been installed to confirm that
they're removing lead and then part of
that
approach is also
posting the other outlets and fixtures
in the school and making sure that those
are not accessible for drinking water
unless they've been tested and
remediated so all of those
those details are spelled out in the
language in hb 1421.
so it really gives schools the option
and schools and child care facilities
the option of doing this route of
testing and remediating every outlet
about five parts per billion or
installing water bottle filling stations
and directing children and students to
be using those to fill their to fill
their water bottles
des feels that this approach would give
schools and child care facilities the
flexibility and feasibility to be able
to reduce exposure to lead and drinking
water
and just for just for context there are
about 750 licensed child care facilities
and about 630 schools
in the state so almost 1400 facilities
that are required to do testing under
the current statute
and from the first round of testing
it
on average schools have been testing
about 32
outlets or 32 fixtures at each at each
school and about seven fixtures at each
child care facility so that has resulted
in about 21 000
individual faucets that have been tested
and we have about 23 000 test results
for for those
for those fixtures
so
that's all take any questions if anyone
has questions thank you all right
representative spang and then
representative egan
um so last time we looked at this issue
i think it was determined that it didn't
make sense to test every
every outlet because the source of the
lead came
from the pipe that served the whole
school
so why not just test that
there's been a change in thinking on
that
so
in terms of so lead is something that
has been historically used in plumbing
fixtures and is actually can be in the
faucet itself it can be used it was
historically used in solder for
piping so it actually can be picked up
within a facility so you could have two
sinks and two different classrooms one
could have lead one
may not have lead so it really for lead
is one of those contaminants that's very
important to test or to really
understand everywhere you're drinking
what the lead concentration is so other
contaminants it's you know as long as
you know what's coming out of the pipe
that's coming into the building you know
it's not going to change but let is
unique in that way right
follow-up for a follow-up thank you or
this is actually another question
um
so i i'm a little um
at a loss here for for how to implement
the des recommendation
are you suggesting that we don't need
if
um if the other bill 421 is passed
or is there an amendment that
needs to be made to one of those bills
to integrate the two
so i i am not familiar enough with the
details of the legislative process and
how that would work but we would
recommend that the provisions of 14 21
be included in sb 452 and then how they
move forward
you know it's up to up to
um
the legislature so i'm not you know i i
think our concern is that that that
we've got two different bills and just
trying to have a holistic approach and
really trying to understand ultimately
what the what the changes are going to
be to the statute
mr chair is is this worth pursuing i'm
not sure exactly if you look at the back
of the uh yeah it was handed out you'll
see
there is a
four fifth
14 21
uh has
water bottle filling stations and
uh this bill sb 452 does does not at the
presence right
so my question is i guess
going forward here
uh 1421
right now does not have some things that
are important
that are in 452
not that i well you could you could read
the
yeah i've taken a look at it
and
it's i'm just trying to i guess the
easiest thing would be if des would say
that their interpretation of the letter
is that we don't need 452. they very
seldom will take that
isn't that what their letter is saying
uh
you can read what they said
knowing
you know knowing most
administration
responses
they s
unless it's
they they will not take sides they will
just give you their information well i
was just asking for clarification of how
to interpret that what they actually
wrote in their letter
uh you
you can you can ask them as
i think i think maybe
we'll move on then okay thank you
you might have also additional comments
by any members relative to her question
representative uh grassy i think uh you
had your hand
representative egan that it's okay we
refer
and then then i'll go to go to you
representative
okay
okay representative grassley then and
then i'll go to representative most of
the things if i'm correct to phrase this
as a question i think it's it's if i'm
correct here most of the provisions that
are in 452 were included in 1421 as part
of the senate amendment is that correct
that's correct so basically what you're
looking at is 452 that we have before us
here
is in
1450 is is in 1421 uh and the five parts
per billion
um
you know that's just a testing standard
that if it's anything's below that and
and uh so
the provisions in in the senate bill
that we have before us today are pretty
much already included in the house
version that was passed by the or that's
before the senate right now i haven't
heard what the standards are
what their decision has been that's
correct so when when hb 1421 was with
the senate education committee des
recommended that they include the
provisions of sb 452 that were not
included so um to make to make for
consistency and to really understand
what the you know the implications for
for the question mr chairman just to as
far as the the water filling stations
are concerned that was something you
folks recommended is giving an
alternative
to local facilities that may have some
problems with certain specific
water stations
you know water outlets and it also did
include if i'm not mistaken in here one
of the comments that was made by a
previous speaker was that they were
concerned about cooking facilities you
do require that anything that's used for
cooking has to meet the lower standard
and be tested
that that's correct unless you're using
a water bottle filling station for
cooking you know i'm not sure the
mechanics of that then you know if you
have using a kitchen sink for cooking
that that would be required for testing
um and so i think you know the bottle
filling station approach could also
alleviate schools from having to test 32
you know that that's the average some
schools would have you know over 100
outlets that they would have to test and
track uh so this would you know give
them
give a more potentially more efficient
approach
and representative post
oh yes representative cullen
thank you thank you mr chair
um
thank you for your testimony um you
mentioned that roughly 21 000 tests are
done or have been done within the last
year
since 2016. since 2016. but i noticed in
the fiscal note tied to your testimony
in 1421 that you're requesting that the
des would then need to add another staff
person is are we not already staffed to
do this and why
would des need to add to that and
secondly it says in there that
first two years come from federal funds
but then the general funds would be
needed to support this position
thereafter but the senator in his
testimony noted that we have
over a million dollars in the trust fund
for drinking water and groundwater
contamination remediation so
why would the
des ask
the fiscal note to be applied here
and create more funds out of the general
fund that would then
cause taxpayer issues
so share some insight
sorry
so the the uh the program manager
position the position that i that i'm in
is a part-time temporary position that
was created about a year ago and it's
funded from a grant from u.s epa
and so that we have funding for the next
two years
i don't know what the funding is going
to be like beyond that
we're anticipating an additional
allotment from epa but we don't know the
specifics of what that's going to look
like and i would anticipate that we
would use a lot of that funding for
remediation but i'm not sure at this
point that'll be determined over the
next few months and so i think with the
part of the reason for the additional
funding for
in the fiscal note for a staff position
is that
currently the way the existing statute
is written is that there's no
requirement to provide the data to des
uh
most of schools that have tested have
provided data about we've got data from
about 95 percent of schools that have
tested uh they're required to provide
data to des if there's an exceedance but
otherwise they're not required to
provide data and so one of the changes
in both of these bills would be that
facilities are would be required to
submit data so there's additional work
on the department's standpoint from in
terms of tracking those data and making
sure that you know that that we have all
the data and any follow-up testing and
remediation information so those are the
um the reasons for the additional
position time and then in terms of the
the funding from the groundwater and
trust fund that is a remediation
only grant for schools for 50
reimbursement and so that doesn't
include any uh funding for staff time
for um administering that grant
so just a quick follow-up mr chair if i
can clarify so
um
so this would require schools to test
and therefore that's why you have the
needed staff and the needed staff would
need to come from funds because the
trust fund is for remedy remediation
yes so the existing statute requires the
testing but there's no requirement to
give the data to dea so that's the
difference and we have federal funding
for at least two years for the position
but beyond that if just you know staff
time is needed there may or may not be
federal funds available thank you so
much for the clarity on that thanks
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i just want to go back a little bit we
were talking about the idea of water
being tested and
in the
area of food and food prep
in my town
the elementary schools do not cook their
phone food anymore they hire companies
that bring it in
is that covered by this do those
companies have to be tested or is there
any
kind of information on that i don't i
don't think so i believe as the current
statute is written and as these bills
are written it's the facility
is required to do any testing of water
in their facility
thank you
representative post and followed by
representative cullen
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony today um my question is
once these faucets are tested and there
is no presence of lead or there is it
meets the requirement
is there continual testing after that
the required 180 days or
how does that work in terms of the
faucets or the filling stations the
faucets so there's uh the way the the
current statute is written as there's
three rounds of testing that are
required
and
i believe the language in the current
sb452 and in hb 1421 would require three
rounds of testing so most schools and
child care facilities schools have done
one round of testing already so they
would need to do two additional rounds
of testing so there would be follow-up
so there would be no more testing
after the three rounds
correct if they were less than the
standard then typically you would have
if you had a faucet that was high and
you replaced it with a low lead fixture
we would
require that that that outlet be tested
you flush flush the line run the water
through it and test it again to make
sure that that actually addressed the
issue and that would be considered part
of like one testing round and then you
would still need to do another testing
round sometime later to confirm that it
was still
one more follow-up
on on the 180 days for the dispensing
water dispensing stations is there a cut
off on that as well or is it ongoing
always for testing
so i believe that the way that that's
written now is that it's a test within
180 days to make sure that that it's
working properly and then beyond that um
no i don't think any
testing would be required but if there's
there would be maintenance that would be
required if there's a some of those
stations have filters that are included
and so
those would need to be maintained and
changed periodically
yes another follow-up so so they don't
have to do any more testing they just
have to be responsible for the
maintenance on a schedule correct all
right thank you
uh representative cohen
yes thank you mr speaker mr speaker i
have a question um of the speaker here
mr chairperson on the comparison chart
but if you decide the question should be
redirected to representative grassy i'm
fine with that okay thank you for taking
my question on your comparison chart
uh you say that the standard and the
senate bill is five parts per billion
and it says in the house bill
15 parts per billion so is that
if both bills are passed as amended
today
the senate bill will have a much lower
standard required
so sorry i should clarify on the on the
chart that the the first column is hb
1421 as it was passed out of the house
and originally it did it didn't change
the standard it left it at the 15 parts
per billion and then when hb 1421 was
being considered by the senate education
committee that's when the
it was it was
changed to have a standard of five parts
per billion so in its current form it
does have five parts per billion thank
you very much for the clarification
any other questions by members of the
committee
representative mayfield
mayfield
thank you for taking my question
i have to go back to some basics here
because i'm failing to see a link i
don't negate the impact of lead in our
water
but my five children are all tested when
they're about 15 months of age so it's
between the ages of one and two
the testimony is telling us that
school-aged children are
poisoned with lead
why are these children being tested then
later are there some developmental
problems that we're seeing rampantly and
suddenly we're saying look we need to
test these kids for lead because there's
a problem here and the cdc says the
greatest risk
to um with health problems is to
children that are exposed under the age
of six yet we're talking about all of
the schools in the state
so i guess i need to see a link between
the tests that we do when they're
toddlers at age one or two
and then the school-aged children that
are coming up with this lead exposure
lead poisoning
when you know my understanding is lead
can be found in water but is much more
prevalent in lead-based paint in toys
from other countries um candy from other
countries cosmetics cleaning supplies
so
i i need some help getting to that point
of i'm testing a kid at the age of one
or two he's exposed in the home now
we're going to the point of there's lead
in the schools and all these children
are you know have lead poisoning so
is it the schools or is it the home
[Music]
there there is a requirement that kids
are tested at ages one and two and if
there's elevated lead concentrations
then that triggers an investigation by
department of health and human services
and they go in and they visit the home
and they look for any kind of potential
appealing pain or other exposures they
test the water so that's a that's a
separate process
my understanding and i'm not i i
i work with that that program to support
them with the water testing results um i
will say that for the testing
that i've seen there's only been a
handful of cases where there's been lead
in the water in the home
that's not to say that that was
necessarily the cause
you know we just provide support on on
the lead results so i'm i'm generally
familiar with the program but uh
there there could be older potentially
older children that get roped into an
investigation
if if there's an issue but i'm not
really familiar with the details of that
and i don't think that there's any
widespread testing done of school-aged
children
so
so where do we get the statistic of this
20 of lead poisoning is in school-aged
children
i believe that was
20 of exposure comes from lead and
drinking water is that what you're
okay
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing none
thank you very much
thank you
so
with that
i will close the hearing
on
[Music]
senate bill 452
we will be taking up
the we will be executing
senate bill 452
during the executive session that is
presently scheduled for
10 45 however
we are going into caucus
the republican caucus and the democrat
caucus
in all probability that is going to take
longer
it's going to take longer than
for uh
uh
well it would be more than 15 minutes
in all probability it will take
at least a half an hour i would guess
there's some controversial issues but
so
uh we will be postponing
the
actual executing till at least 11
o'clock
uh i will put a note on the door
that we will be you know postponing
because this the
republicans will be meeting in this room
and
representative smith here
in room 403
okay uh i'll ask
representative smith to have her her
cell phone on that when she's finished
to call us if the republicans are
finished first we'll call her so that we
can just
get back together again
because we may even go beyond the
1105. which will be
what i think we will
go to
uh with that
i will
i will ask that the room
be cleared you know we are not and with
the postponement is that for the or put
a note on the
door that uh we are going into a car
into caucus uh
and uh that
execs at 1105 or later you may see
somebody come out and change it
turn on the mic
call the executive session to order we
have
uh
we just we we finished uh
the hearing on senate bill
earlier in the uh
earlier than in the morning
and
why don't we go right into
[Music]
senate bill 572
uh
452. wow
i knew these things cut off too much
oxygen
all right
but they said oh you're always sound
like that yeah okay
all right 452
uh
which is the relative to lead in in
drinking water in schools and licensed
child care facilities
uh the chair recognizes representative
harb for a motion thank you
thank you mr chair and i'd like to make
a motion to itl this bill
and uh do i
do i hear a second
representative cry
representative creighton
uh
representative harb would you like to
speak to your motion yes although in
principle i can see the benefits of
senate bill 452 i support the house bill
um
1421 as uh currently amended by the
senate i think we have some duplication
i
read the des reports so i moved to an
expedient to legislate on this
particular bill
representative creighton to speak on
your uh on your motion
i concur with uh representative hart
it was saying to me that one bill that
accomplishes the same task would be
much preferable than two bills that
trying to do the same thing
and i think that the house bill
laid it out better
than the senate bill and with less
with less adjustment it has to be made
sir anyone else
representative connors speak on your
speak on the on the bill
thank you um well i do agree that 1421
seems to be the best alternative here
would it make more sense
to do an otp on 452 and then make a
motion on the house floor to hold this
bill by tabling it
until we know what happens with
14 21.
okay
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on the
on the motion
rep representative cohen yes thank you
for taking my speak on us i i agree with
representative connor and since for an
executive session could i ask you to
randy your opinion on what she said
my my opinion will be in my vote
but we
that's correct
that's correct but we are having a
discussion where we any of us could
change our our what we're thinking of
voting
so
did representative connors
uh
our discussion
possibly i don't know what your vote's
going to be i'm assuming you're going to
support the itl at this point
does it influence you in any way
where you may think that that might have
some validity or weight that doesn't
it's not a reasonable thing to do based
on this new information that she
provided to you
uh
well only we're all the information
should right around now the information
that i hear is only a suggestion
and
that's all others may
think differently representative grassy
then followed by representative harp
yes uh mr chairman i um
i sort of agree um with representative
cronus i think that instead of otp i'd
rather see it
oh yeah as otp
yeah
i'd want to see it as ought to pass and
table it because i think one of the
concerns we have is basically the
entirety of 452 is in 1421.
uh 452 is a good bill
the thing is is that if the senate
finance committee decides not to and the
senate its wisdom decides not to pass
1421 we end up with nothing
what is in
452 is basically some minimal standards
which we should be approving anyway
and i and i just have a fear that if we
have it as
interim study we've lost our opportunity
for this year if the senate does not
pass 14 15 14 21
uh so i i think that we should have you
know we should vote ought to pass and we
should vote to table it when it comes to
the floor so that it's there
depending what the senate does if the
senate passes 1421 we just leave it on
the table if the
senate defeats 1421 we pull it off the
table and we we do it that way i mean
the basic provisions of 452 in 1421
1421 passed out of the senate five to
nothing out of the senate education
committee
five to nothing
so if you're looking at that i think
there's a lot of support in the senate
for the bill but you really don't know
what they're going to do until they take
that final vote so it's just a concern
that i have
i'm i'm looking at the docket of hb 1421
and uh it says the committee report has
ought to pass with amendment
from the senate that's out of the
education not the finance committee from
what i understand they haven't voted on
it yet and it's not due to the floor
until 4 28.
that that was my comment was that i
would endure sorry if i may miss chair
um i just checked and it actually came
out of senate finance voted in favor of
it 7-0
so just today then we don't have a
problem
this is up from the 20th
that's today and the report is ought to
pass with amendments okay mine was
didn't get updated when just half an
hour ago it it's it wasn't updated so
great they passed it today we're all set
then okay no problems i'm fine all right
oh you agree with me representative
exactly i was
okay just double checking my all right
any other questions
any other comments
on the motion
on the motion to uh
itl as i said
by representative harp
uh seeing no other comments will the
clerk please call the roll
yes thank you chair on the motion of itl
uh representative harb yes
representative huff
yes
representative gould
representative horgan yes
representative creighton yeah
representative notter
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
healey yes representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith yes representative
spang yes
representative grassy
representative gottling yes
representative cohen
no
representative connors
representative vale
yes
representative kelly yes representative
perez
yes
and representative egan yes
representative zula
yes
okay
that is
yeah that's twenty one yep
okay cc
incent
let's see
it will be on the consent calendar
uh and we let's see
martin
uh
okay
all right uh
since we have uh
yeah
uh
senator here uh right now who's uh you
know he's busy
senators are busy they should
they shouldn't be sitting here well so
let's get him uh on on his way on senate
bill 305
uh
[Music]
representative smith's for motion i make
a motion not to pass on
senate bill 305
do i have a second
i'll second
all right who was that
all right representative egan ii
right
uh
representative smith do you wish to
speak on your motion of course
this bill is
improves upon a situation that we have
run into in the
area of hampton falls to hampton harbor
in the marshland there which two three
years ago we passed legislation
prohibiting personal watercraft in that
area
but we then found out
once the bill was enacted the law was
enacted that there were people who had
their personal watercraft in that area
and they couldn't get out
and it was very limiting and so this
bill um makes it so they can be in that
channel only in the channel
but going at headway speed which is the
lowest speed you can go
to not create any wake
and then last year we had a bill which
the governor vetoed which prohibited
personal watercraft in the area of the
newcastle rye estuary area and we even
went on a field trip um probably a week
before we shut down from coven
and so that bill was vetoed for a
similar reason
probably
because
anyone who already had a personal
watercraft there couldn't get in or out
of that area
so this bill also adds that area at
headway speed to that
area of newcastle
and
and rye
and the areas outlined in the rye and
rye harbor marsh
are the parameters which marine patrol
said would be very easy for them to
patrol
so it's i think it's a good bill and we
should pass it
briefly yes i think we've this has some
a lot of logic in this bill and that's
why i support it
anyone
anybody
wish to speak on this on the motion
of off to pass
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
on the motion of out to pass for senate
bill 305 representative harb yes
representative huff
yes
representative gould
representative horgan yes
representative creighton
representative notter yes the clerk
votes yes representative healy yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith yes
representative spang
representative
grassy representative gottling yes
representative cohen yes representative
connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez
yes
representative egan yes
chairman zulu
yes
21-0 passed
cece
yep
it goes on onto the consent calendar
when he went to nothing
uh thank you
all right uh
why don't we go to
uh
we got a
senate bill 258.
two okay that's right all right let's go
257. senate bill 257 uh
[Music]
which is enabling municipalities to
incorporate sewage disposal systems as
part of their storm water utility
uh
chair recognizes
representative harb for a motion thank
you mr chair i'd like to make a motion
to interim study senate bill 257
is there a second oh second
representative harvard
uh ebola just like to speak on your
motion
representative harp thank you mr chair
uh
the bill is an interesting bill i do
think it needs further study i've looked
at the testimony from the board of
realtors and other parties concerning 50
of all septic systems are private in the
state
uh i think this bill as presently worded
might have unintended consequences but
i'd like to study it further hence my
motion for internal study
would you like to speak on your second
uh just briefly i concur with
representative harp and the financial
implications of this bill require study
but it is a worthy cause of
uh we need to study that
a way to get nitrogen
out of the great bay area thanks very
much okay
to anyone who's just to speak on the uh
on the motion representative spain
it's been killing the bill for sure
but um i feel that
the um
it doesn't need to be studied in order
to make it workable
because it's basically enabling
legislation the details will be worked
out by each municipality
according to what
their
their financial needs are their
infrastructure capability is
and what uh the
their
residential property owners
are interested in doing
um i feel that the
the lack of understanding
which was
greatly exacerbated by the realtors lack
of understanding of the bill
is more a matter of
this committee becoming more comfortable
with it and understanding that the
financial problems that are being
suggested
are really a non-issue
so
the
i think we're going to be seeing more
municipalities that adopt
the stormwater utility which will make
everybody more comfortable with how that
whole mechanism works
and then of course how this would
play into it also
so although i'm disappointed not to be
able to pass this and
give it an opportunity to to
be tried out
or at least to be discussed by at the
municipal level to decide whether it has
possibilities for each municipality
i do think that it's very important that
this idea be kept alive
as the
chair of the shoreline septic system
commission
we realize that something must be done
about the enormous amount or percentage
of nitrogen that is coming out of
individual septic systems
it's a bear to attack because of the
concern about private property rights
and the costs of upgrading
an individual septic system
as des said there are programs out there
to help munici uh individuals to upgrade
their septic systems
um and we i think that
we need to make sure that we explore
those more so that we understand them
so i as i say i would
i would prefer that we interim study
this one not to defer it but to actually
do some serious study of how it will
work get some input from municipalities
i don't have any use for
the
realtor's
input on it because i think that they're
misleading
but
so i i support the
the interim study motion
is there anyone else with
with the
comment
or a
comment on the bill representative smith
thank you mr chair
i would agree with representative spanx
summation as much as i would like to see
this enabling legislation passed i do
understand concerns about the costs
because it it is
you know it is an unknown factor but the
gr the area of the great bay has been
under
i don't want to say attack but you know
the um
the epa and the ms4 permitting and the
wastewater treatment plant upgrades that
are not covering a hundred percent of
the problem of the nitrogen and we do
know that home septic systems are a huge
uh issue
and we also have interim studied another
bill on shoreline septic systems so i
truly hope that by interim studying this
that we really are going to study the
two of these bills because they both
have to do with shoreland septic and
discharges into our lakes the great bay
ponds and rivers
and that's all
okay
i think i need to say something
first i've got to probably
reevaluate what's going on because i
happen to agree with the father
the previous two speakers
we do need
to actually spend a lot of time
to determine what exactly this
this means and what also
what this but this bill meant
and also how to address the issues
around
uh
the uh
was it mp4
mp4
uh
ms4 well it's close
that
those
those issues
the
i also say that this bill
as it was written
i would never have considered what
i would never have expected the
testimony to say the things they did and
describe what they did
based on this bill reading it
stuff was very
it maybe it was me but it was
you know
when the testimony basically showed that
they were going to have the authority to
the tax
that uh did when i hear someone say well
we're going to charge everybody with a
septic system of fifteen hundred dollars
and then we're going to drop uh
the uh
the when they when we find that they've
done certain things that we like we'll
give them some rebates
uh uh
no
i so we d we the legislature has to be
doing
has to
retain the power
of taxation and we cannot delegate it to
the
to the local authorities but beyond that
but to get back to the actual
amendment or the actual uh
motion i i also agree with the with the
motion of interim study and it will be a
real interim
study you know i mean any other
questions comments will the clerk play
in seeing none will the clerk please
call the role
oh i'm sorry
question of the chair when can we start
working on this bill you want to stay
over
this afternoon
how about next week
we'll we'll do it as soon as we
as soon as we
were able
uh will
clerk please call the roll
thank you mr chair
on senate bill 257 motion of interim
study representative harp yes
representative huff yes representative
gold
representative horgan yes representative
creighton yes
representative notter yes the clerk
votes yes representative healy yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes
representative smith yes representative
spang
representative grassy
representative gottling yes
representative cohen yes
representative connors
representative vale yes
representative kelly yes
representative perez
yes
representative egan yes
chairman zulu
yes
21-0
being 21-0
bc
okay consent
all right
uh no it goes on the calendar
yeah oh yeah it goes on uh
calendar
and we have to write a report
on
the interim study at the end of the year
uh
the
usually in october
now senate bill 258
relative to
the graves
of african americans alive during the
period of american enslavement
uh chair recognizes representative huff
for a motion
thank you mr chairman um i
move that
senate bill 258
the uh for interim study and i'd like to
speak to my motion uh when i have a
moment and get a second
all right you need a second we'll do
for a second
representative
post representative for the speak on
your motion
thank you mr chairman
um
colleagues first i'd i'd like to just
start by uh
saying i think we can all agree
that the preservation of our national
heritage as well as our state heritage
is um is super important
especially for those of our citizens who
the goal of our our nation at the time
of being free um hadn't been realized
yet for all citizens
um the relics and gravesites and remains
and preserves recorded
uh deserved being recorded and preserved
and celebrated
now with that said there were several
issues that i had with this bill and i'd
like to just bring them up
for you
to understand why i think it's important
that we have to study this
the first and foremost difficulty i had
with with the bill is in the um
is what the senator uh
uh in testimony
uh alluded to as far as uh
changing one of the definitions and one
of the definitions that was changed
or added i should say was
for
the african-american descendant
community
the definition in this was means persons
of african-american
descent
residing in the municipality
or designated representatives which
makes absolutely sense and then he added
the black heritage trail of new
hampshire
which he testified to us was
a non-profit that he founded
i'm not so comfortable with having a
a fiduciary responsibility that should
be carried out by the state
basically given to a private entity
um
it also goes on to mention um
in the in in the entirety of the bill
all of the different um statutes that
already deal with this subject
um
as far as uh discovery as far as finding
out what what they need to do with it
they've all been addressed they're
already in statute and if there was ever
a catch-all
um for something that they didn't know
how to handle or didn't know what to do
with
um they referred to it in to the um af
the uh
native american statutes
which handle any of these things
so that's one of the major problems that
i had with this
so i i really think it it needs to be
looked at also another just a a piece of
information i looked up um because it
was concerning to me about this uh
there are other
organizations in the state
that also do
what the uh what the foundation of the
black uh heritage trail of new hampshire
does
so why this was specifically um
singled out
i'm not going to speculate
but i think it needs to be looked at
and i'm sure there's an answer
that that can be had and and i think an
interim study would be able to address
these concerns
i'll take any
questions or
i agree
i agree with the representative and um
uh believe this is the right thing to do
put it in an interim study
is there anyone else who wish to speak
on the motion
oh
representative cohen
i appreciate um the motion that there's
a sentiment to fix a problem
but i feel that
this bill will start to address the
problem
i'm not clear in my interpretation of
the bill
that if the one organization that was
listed that's culturally sensitive to
the issues would actually be able to
mandate
that this
the state of the local municipality
has to spend a certain amount of money
in a certain way and i feel that putting
this to interim study will delay this at
least another year before something
happens so i will not be supporting
the interim study that do appreciate
that there is some sentiment for this
bill
but suggesting there's some changes
represent representative
smith for
you were
yeah thank you mr chair um i think that
the in my study of the various groups
the black heritage trail appears to be
the one that has the most broad
influence
and uh does the most for the
african-american black community
and
they
do a lot of workshops and studies and
although the senator may have been one
of the founders of the organization they
have a a large group they have an
executive director they've got a board
of directors it's not a one-man show and
it you know i'm not sure when it was
founded i'm sure it was quite a while
ago you know 10 years maybe
so i think that that is kind of
irrelevant and i think that having when
you have someone who is
uh they don't know who
the you know i think that adding that to
the mix is a good idea i mean if you
wanted to just take that out that would
be fine but other than that i think it
is a bill that is long overdue
there has been so much work being done
in the last
few years especially and
new hampshire was a
state where a lot of black people did
migrate to
either escaping slavery or
moving here because there was a more a
free it was more able to be a free
person here
and so i think that this bill is
necessary
and for the heritage
of the people and the heritage of the
state so i will be voting against the
interim study
okay
now
is there any oh
i don't know
all right
pardon yes
you could you can speak then
representative
it seems to me that
in principle that
there are people on this committee who
really
support this
and i am wondering what is the harm
in passing it
i mean we can nitpick our way through it
but
overall
i think that there is a lot to be gained
from it and i just don't see that there
any of this stuff that we're bringing up
should impede the passage of the bill
thank you mr chair
i also will be opposing the
interim study i think this bill is
overdue honestly and i know
that
my dealings with african-american
people in my community and with the
black heritage trail
that it is really important to anyone
from any culture to be able to recover
the bodies of their dead and to give
them a proper burial and i don't think
we're talking about any old you know i
know i understand that there are other
cultures and there are other situations
and there are other laws but i bel i
believe that in a unique
circumstance that we have with
african-american burleigh grounds in the
united states that we should treat that
specifically and separately because a
lot of people were tortured their bones
were not respected they were used for
medical experiments they were used to
make products
such as leather
so
if there's just
to me this bill is a matter of respect
and that's why i'll be voting against
the it uh the interim study
representative grassy then then
representative
yeah i i would also oppose the interim
study on this bill i think it the bill
is is very well written as far as as
dealing with the issue of
african-american burial areas
as someone who is a town planner for 20
years and served on a planning board for
an additional 10 years in my local
community
i found many instances when we dealt
with situations like this and in
rochester we didn't have a large black
community at all so we never ran into
these we ran into grave sites that were
found during construction
during the approval process and when
when when the engineers and experts went
out to the sites
to find things
unbeknownst to anyone
we'd find unmarked graves or we'd find
graves that were
not
really documented very well
and what this bill addresses is the fact
that
when you're dealing with
african-american graves there was a
greater tendency not to document these
things or not to mark them very well
and what we're doing is we're addressing
a wrong here
that yeah you know uncle joe may have
been buried out on the back farm but
when it came to those freed slaves that
came to new hampshire that didn't have
families in the area
they were many cases put into poppers
graves
or graveyards which were not well marked
at all
and as dealing with the new hampshire
heritage trail they're just a group that
if there is no descendant community in
that area that would basically take the
responsibility to pick up um the care of
of these and what happens to these grave
sites or the uh the the materials that
are recovered from these grave sites
including the bodies of of these uh men
and women who were buried there
and i think that is is beyond the time
that we take some action on this
and again as someone who's worked in the
community worked in the field as far as
the development is concerned when we
find these things
these black grave sites are just as
important as any others
and a lot of times we stumble upon them
and they should be given the respect and
i think that's one of the things that
this bill does and i would hope that we
would oppose interim study we there's
really no need to study this any further
and we approve this
you have any
anyone else to speak on this bill or
that's i'm sorry representative
with
all the respect for my democrat
colleagues i
will support the entry study
i will support it because i want to know
what are the bills that we have going on
that support other communities not just
that
black carriage um
and i'm probably like controversial
right now but um i just feel like
we have many other communities there i
would like to see that happening
for that reason i will support the entry
study
well
anyone
else uh wish to speak on the motion
seeing no one else
motion of interim study full court
please call the roll
thank you
uh on house uh senate bill 258
representative harb yes
representative huff
yes
representative golds
representative horrigan yes
representative creighton yeah
representative notter yes
clerk votes yes representative healey
yes
representative mayville yes
representative post yes representative
smith no
representative spang
representative grassy no
representative gotling no
representative cohen
no
representative connors
representative vale
no
representative kelly
representative perez
yes
representative egan
representative renzolu
yes okay so that's twenty
thirty
thirteen
eight three
will write the report
thirteen to eight i'm sorry thirteen to
eight i wanted to recount
eight yeah thirteen days twelve minutes
yeah
yep
thirteen yep will there be a minority
report
representative cullen oh i'm sorry no no
no what
it's 13 days all right
11 republicans two down yeah
yep thank you
all right
[Music]
now of
that being
uh is that's any other business uh
that's that's it for uh
the
executive session
uh is there any other business before
the uh committee
uh i do want the reports on this
uh
i certainly can't
i don't know i don't think you can do
them tomorrow if you do you're going to
be
wonderful can you can i have can i have
them buddy on the friday
okay if you got them great because uh
you know i've got to go over them and
uh and the and of course
representative smith
is going to need the time too so
all right
yep representative kelly and then
representative uh
oh i just wanted to say i think this
will possibly be the last time we're
meeting as a group or maybe last time
possibly mike i just want to say it was
a pleasure working with everybody here
and i had the pleasure of serving on
science and technology yesterday and i
just want to say that this is a much i
feel that this environment is much more
uh
collegiate yeah exactly perfect word and
i feel uh you know ideas are always
shared and it feels great to work with
you also just want to say that thank you
it's actually are you going to say the
same thing
i was basically going to echo that this
is my first time with r d and fish and
game and i think folks that are focused
on the environment are collegial and
collaborative and i really appreciated
being the new guy and letting me pass
out papers to you all it made me feel
good thank you representative spain
thank you um i
got a confirmation that tomorrow is
indeed tartan day
so um all of you uh who have the least
bit of tartan
even if it's a bow for your hair we're
not very particular about whether
one is
uh of scottish descent or whether one is
uh
the only big italian american the only
thing i have to do with anything
scottish is in a bottle
so
[Laughter]
that's a good enough reason you can go
get yourself a tartan a
state tartan tie at the
gift shop and you can do an online order
anyone else
yeah this may be the last time but well
we believe that we will be meeting a
trip
field trip field trip
uh let's see is there going to be a
field
i just want to say thank you for having
me in this committee
i've been telling you that i really
enjoy being here i i i feel like um
it's similar to my committee so i
definitely um you know i hopefully if i
run again for every election i would
love to be in this committee because i
definitely can see working with you guys
thank you
thank you and
yeah representative you're uh you're a
two you're a two-timer as well
a double
and and i would say that i i would echo
uh my colleagues uh uh sentiments at
this is a very collegial and nice and
and and friendly committee my labor
committee is slightly more contentious
um so i appreciate it here and i thank
you and i hope to see you all again next
time
and picture
yeah i don't know if there's a picture
used to be there we have to take a
picture at the end
you got the camera right there
there will be
some uh
probably going to be some of the biggest
today
most of the time
technically the uh
if
thank you mr chair i would like to thank
very much the efforts of our committee
chair
representative renzullo
and our minority leader representative
smith
and also the often unapplauded efforts
of our clerk
it's a terrific job and thank you very
much
yes and representative harp
thank you
you